من الدفاع الى الهجوم تريد كيف تغيير
استراتيجيتها العسكريه ومن اجل هذا تلحول
الحصول على الدبابات الغربيه وفي مقدمتها
دبابات اليوبارد اثنين المانيه الصنع لكن
برلين تشترط لارسال دباباتها لاوكرانيا
ارسال واشنطن دبابات ابرامز اولا تردد
حاولت بعض الدول الاوروبيه كسره لانها
تمتلك هذا النوع من الدبابات الهجوميه
اصلا هنا الحديث عن بولندا وفنلندا ودول
البلطي لكنها اصطدمت ببنود العقد الموقعي
مع الدوله المصنعه تطالب برلين الدول التي
تحصل على اسلحه المانيه الصنع بالحصول على
موافقتها قبل اي تصدير الى دوله ثالثه
مع ان بريطانيا اعلنت ارسال دبابات
تشالنجر 2 الى اوكرانيا الى ان هذه
الاخيره تريد المزيد تعلل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عدم ارسال دبابات ابرام
بان التدريب عليها يحتاج وقتا طويلا وخشيه
من عدم قدره الاوكرانيين على الصيانه مع
كل هذا تتدفق المساعده الاوروبيه على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت في لندن انها ستقدم
مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيه بقيمه اربع مئه
مليون يورو وهي الاكبر لها حتى الان وتشمل
مدفعيه وذخيره لكنها لا تتضمن دبابات
اليوبار اثنين الثقيله وتعهدت السويد
بارسال منظومه
وصواريخ مضاده للدبابات
تباين وسط دول داعمه لاوكرانيا حول
الامدادات العسكريه يرى المراقبون انه
سيطيل عمر المعارك المستمره على الارض